[Music]
former president ronald reagan died
saturday he was 93 the longest living
president
mr reagan's body will lie in state in
the u.s capitol rotunda his funeral will
be at the national cathedral with his
burial at the reagan presidential
library in california
washington journal will start an hour
earlier than usual at six a.m eastern
with four hours remembering ronald
reagan
next reagan biographer lou cannon in
1991 he was on book notes for two hours
lou cannon author of the book president
reagan the role of a lifetime
what's the trep toe story marvin trepto
was a
hero in world war one he was he was
killed
they found a uh
a
diary on him and he expressed in it uh
his devotion to to to his country ronald
reagan told a story about him at the in
the first inaugural speech uh when he
was originally inaugurated as president
and
he also said that trepto or implied that
trepto was buried at arlington
uh across the river which you could see
the synagogue was on the west front of
the capitol in fact
he knew that marvin trepto had been
buried in bloomer wisconsin because his
aides had pointed it out to him but
ronald reagan thought it made a better
story to say that marvin trepto
was buried in arlington how often do you
do things like that from time to time i
i don't i don't uh
uh i don't know the frequency but he
he believed that a story should have uh
a symbolic narrative purpose and he said
to a columnist who had asked him
there's a there's a story in the book
about a columnist who
remembered how how ronald reagan in the
film brother rat had come in and sat in
the drug store in his hometown of
lexington virginia and he and he'd been
telling the story for years and ronald
reagan leaned over and told the
columnist he said i was never in
lexington and then said that that he had
been in hollywood they had shot his part
of the film in hollywood the columnist
was was really mortified that he had
gotten this wrong this is charlie
mcdonald charlie mcdowell whom you know
who is the sort of the will rogers of of
uh american columnist one of the one of
the great uh columnist i think and uh
charlie was had said well how can this
be i've told the story many many times
and reagan asked him how many times
did you see the movie and he'd seen the
movie a lot and and
and reagan said well you wanted me to be
there you put me in that you've seen the
movie and you remember me as having been
in that town and he said don't feel
badly about it he said i do it all the
time myself so the fact is ronald reagan
did do that sort of things
a lot he didn't lie he didn't say trepto
is buried in arlington he gave the
impression
to the people who were listening that he
was buried there
and and really the point that ronald
reagan was making was what this this man
had sacrificed for his country and uh
he's and and should be remembered and
other people have to make sacrifices for
their country the point was really was
was really valid it's just that ronald
reagan was a performer an actor he
valued this part of his presidency and
he took dramatic license in his stories
i tell the mcdowell story in in response
to you asking me to tell the trepto
story because
i think that there it shows that on some
level
ronald reagan was was much brighter than
people
like to say he was that he knew what he
did that he had he understood the power
of storytelling i quote a uh
an authority on
intelligence in the book as saying that
ronald reagan made sense of the world
narratively he was not
a good analyst he was not a lot he
didn't have a high
intelligence in in the way scientists
and lawyers do
uh uh analytical logical intelligence
but intelligence but he had a a a great
understanding of people and of the power
of storytelling stories move us
ronald reagan knew that he had the
capacity to do to to do that and on some
level at least
some of the time he knew what it was he
did
where did he get these stories
he got them from
everywhere he got them from newspaper
clippings you know he had been on the
road for general electric theater in the
50s ronald reagan was afraid to fly so
he took the train from place it was in
his contract in fact that that he
wouldn't fly
and he would clip out the pa the papers
in the little towns across
america
in those days which is is is 40 years
ago uh there was a lot a lot more
individualism among the american press
than there is today i mean when we
television was we were just at the
beginning of of television and uh
and there were a lot of distinctive
stories that happened in places that
didn't get repeated
uh on every wire service or in every and
every paper in the world
he got the stories from people that he
talked to he has a terrific memory for
anecdote and story uh he
he he remembered stories from his youth
and refashioned them
uh he'd been a sportscaster and his
specialty as a as a sports announcer was
in recreating baseball games which means
describing a game that he never saw
from information that had come over the
the telegraph so he he both invented
stories he retold stories he recast
stories he remembered stories and he
read stories
at some point in your book you talk
about how the staff like to keep human
events away from him
well sure because uh
uh a lot what is it by the way
well i mean i i you you you characterize
human events uh human events is a
washington weekly it's an
ultra-conservative washington weekly and
uh and uh
it's
there were members of reagan's staff
who felt that it it brought out his
doctrinaire or ideological impulses uh
ronald reagan can be
extremely naive in some ways that is to
say he believes what he reads in the
newspapers not not just what he reads in
human events he believes what he reads
in the washington post or the new york
times or the des moines register uh and
and
and he he is apt to take it literally
and he would sometimes repeat a
statistic
that that either was wrong or the staff
thought was wrong so they
they tried to uh they tried to uh to
keep keep it from him so uh so that he
wouldn't uh spout some
point of view that may or may not in the
staff's opinion have been backed by fact
this is the third book you've written
about ronald reagan about ronald reagan
well i always said i was going to keep
writing about reagan till i got it right
i don't know whether i did but i tried
you first met him in 1965 where uh it
was a it was i can't remember the small
town in sacramento but it was in
california it might have been sacramento
but i think it was a smaller town he was
going around the state
giving little speeches and the speeches
were the brainchild of his management
team of
stu spencer and bill roberts
reagan at that time was planning on
running for governor
and the democrats thought he would be
such a weak opponent they wanted to get
him they they wanted to get him
nominated and reagan was going around
the state giving these speeches to show
that he was not just an actor reciting
his lines and typically he would give a
little
very short speech sort of saying what
his views were a lot of generalities and
not much of anything really but then he
would answer questions the purpose of
these speeches were
of these forums were to show that he in
fact could answer questions and that he
wasn't he wasn't just uh
uh uh a person who who
who could not function without a script
over the years how many times have you
been with him one-on-one only two people
in the room oh
i don't know with only two people in the
room is hard because sometimes he'll be
a press secretary but where i've just
been interviewing him but you know 40 45
times
maybe 50 times has he changed at all
during those years the only change that
i recognize in ronald reagan is in his
hearing his hearing he he his hearing is
not good now i mean it
it's
even with hearing aids it's he doesn't
hear well and he heard
in 65 he had he heard perfectly well
has he changed in
other ways has he changed in in the core
way he is no i think there's some way in
which ronald reagan never changes i mean
he has a he has a
a
way he makes sense of the world uh in my
my last book on him i did i reprinted
part of a speech he gave
for hubert humphrey when hubert humphrey
was running for the senate and it had
the sort of same
you listen to the speech or you read it
i actually had a tape of it and it was
the same reagan it had the same sort of
goofy statistics you know he never met a
statistic he didn't like he had a 90
year old carpenter
or there he was or he was quoting or
something and and and he had this kind
of of
nice sort of rounded story that has a
you know he liked happy endings he liked
stories that made a point no there's
some way in which
ronald reagan is
is always ronald reagan whether he was
democrat republican liberal conservative
no i don't think he's changed nancy
reagan by the way once
was at a at one of the national
political conventions and she was asked
by
a publisher whether whether
nancy whether ronald reagan had changed
at all and she said
i he hasn't changed one bit and she
turned to me and she said right lou and
i said that's the way i see it and then
they ask her the question and she said
which i also agree with that she changed
a lot
lyndon offsinger
who used to work for ronald reagan i
assume you know him fairly well yes
wrote a uh review of your book
in the washington times
and um
one of the things
let me just read a little bit of what he
said here he said
although the title and early pages of
the book suggest that mr reagan was
merely an actor starring in the role of
president mr cannon eventually and
almost reluctantly
finds that that
is a serious
oversimplification of what this complex
and puzzling man is all about
do you agree with that reluctantly
finding that well no there's no
reluctance on it i i
uh
i thought that
lin's review considering that he's
totally devoted to ronald reagan
and uh
and has and is very conservative was was
was very fair and and very kind to me
even and i appreciate it but
but i had something different in mind
uh about
reagan the performer and i had something
different in mind as a title here as the
role the role of a lifetime is the
subtitle of this book
ronald reagan valued acting
i understand why why lyndon wrote those
words because usually the
the jibe that reagan was only an actor
or was a b-movie actor or one of these
things where
was said to run him down that it that it
that he was not as if somehow being an
actor he was not worthy of being a
politician or being certainly of being a
president i mean he was portrayed reagan
was in his very first campaign as a guy
who couldn't hold his own with a
chimpanzee you know in bedtime for bonzo
what i was trying the point that i was
trying to make
both with the title and in the book is
that ronald reagan
is a person who values the performance
and who thinks of himself as a performer
after he was elected
governor and he was asked what kind of a
governor he would make he said i don't
know i've never played a governor when
he left the white house
he was asked about how acting had helped
him
be president
and he said i don't understand how
anybody could do this job without having
been
an actor so ronald reagan didn't run
away
from the fact
that he was an actor he he was proud of
it and
and it somewhat distorted his presidency
i think in the sense that that
what he did best and valued most was the
performance aspect of the presidency
what what theodore roosevelt had
referred to as the bully pulpit part of
the presidency i happen to think that is
an important part of the presidency
reagan believed that his immediate
predecessors presidents carter and
presidents ford had not been
particularly skilled in that aspect of
the presidency i agree with that too but
i don't agree with the idea that the
performance
aspect of the presidency is
is so dominant that it should drive out
other
parts of the presidency the way the way
that it it did during during many of the
reagan years but
in the sense that
that that
review was discussing it the notion that
that reagan was
the the canard that reagan was only an
actor or merely an actor i don't see by
the way why
the acting profession seems to be as
respectable as the professions of
uh
from which
politic other
most conventional politicians are drawn
to law
journalism you know you
name it but
but the sense in which the
reagan is is run down as an actor is
that he is speaking somebody else's
lines that somebody else prepares the
script as i say in there and it's not
reluctant at all it was a script of his
own devising he came to the presidency
wanting to do
essentially three things
cut taxes raised the military budget
spending he which he thought had had
gone way down uh since the vietnam years
and and also balanced the budget now he
accomplished the first two and he didn't
accomplish the third because of the
first two uh in my view it was
no economist has yet explained to me how
you can you can cut taxes and
significantly boost military spending
and not come out with
a huge deficit which is what he did
you met him in 65 um what were you doing
then i was a reporter for the san jose
mercury news
where did you grow up uh i i grew up
largely in nevada i grew up in
reno in fallon nevada and i spent many
of my summers on a farm that's uh
now underwater from folsom lake in
california
and
i've really sort of considered myself a
westerner i i i went to uh to school in
nevada and california where'd you go to
college uh university of nevada
it was then just the university of
nevada now it's university of nevada
reno and also briefly before i went into
the service
san francisco state
where did you get interested in
journalism
i've been interested in journalism all
my life i used to
when i was a kid i remember we'd play a
football game on the farms and i must
have been all of seven or eight and i'd
go and i'd write a story of the game i
always wanted to be a reporter i don't
know why no idea where it came from i
have absolutely no idea
but but i but i know that it was
something when i when i was
i was editor of my high school paper i
used to write
i started out as a sports right i used
to write sports for the
local paper in reno when i was when i
was still in high school
your family what'd your mother and
father do
my my my father
was a uh
uh
a nomadic uh
character he his
his family had come had come uh
uh from ireland and had and had they
were farmers and moved and his his uh
mother died giving birth to him he was
largely raised by his sisters and he
took off at an early age and he went all
over the west he worked as a lumber mill
he well he he did all kinds of things
his father had been a stage driver uh
over donner pass and he went east and
and he and he married my mother
uh who was from her family was was from
from hungary and they came back out west
and they were they uh
grew up in reno they ran a store
together and my father went back when he
was later in life and
farmed again he was a classic case of
you could get the
boy off the farm but you couldn't get
the farm out of the boy
and
he was a
i don't we don't do commercials on
c-span but he was a heavy smoker and
he died of emphysema
far too young in life
i want to get back to it but there's
also a lot of talk in your book about
your father being an alcoholic as was
ronald reagan's father i just think i
know there's not a lot of talk of it i
put it in a footnote my father was named
jack as was reagan's father he was an
irish american as was reagan's father
and i and i think
since i i pay a lot of attention to
the influence that this had on reagan it
seemed to me that that a biographer owes
it to his readers to say hey maybe i'm
interested in this because
i had a similar circumstance actually
i've always thought it gave me some
empathy to to reagan
uh and i and
maybe it did i just that's sort of a
truth and advertising label i think that
people should know
where their biographers or where their
reporters are coming from
when you got out of
college where did you go
i was in well i was i was actually uh
drafted i during the during the korean
war i went into the army uh i never got
to uh
korea although i i volunteered for it
but
probably very fortunately for me i
didn't get there
and uh then
when i got out of the army i
i guess i sort of bummed around i drove
a truck for a while i did different
things i worked in political campaign
and
but i i really had this sort of uh
view that i would have been be a
reporter and then i want to uh
and then i want to write books i've
always wanted to do that and i went into
some little paper
in northern california and took they
gave a story test you know they give you
i don't remember they used to do those
things they
fax and scrambled order and
and i was able to put them into
good order and since i didn't have much
experience they could hire me very
cheaply they that was always a great
premium at newspapers
in those days and
so i got the job
when did you get to the san jose mercury
news
that was a number the the story i'm
telling you was in the mid 50s i guess i
went to work for the
san jose mercury after working for two
or three other papers
in
the early 1960s and how long did you
stay there
well i stayed there
really till
i came to washington in
in
1969 i came back to washington for
what was then ritter publications there
they they merged and
several years later with the knight
newspaper organization knight ritter is
now
as many of your your
viewers will know is one of the large
newspaper
chains in the united states the three
books you've written about ronald reagan
the first one was what year first one
was written in uh
68 i guess it was published in 69 it was
called ronnie in jazz political odyssey
it was about reagan and
jess under this uh
larger-than-life character unfortunately
now dead
jess big daddy unruh who was the most
powerful democrat in california
then i the second book about reagan i
wrote was in uh
right at when i was
working for the washington post and
right after he became president was
published in 1982
it was called reagan a title that a
friend of mine in the white house said
good it's so simple even he'll remember
it had no subtitle
and this is uh
this is this is the
last book
i've been working on it for some time
when did you start working on this well
in terms of the of
of the uh actual working on the book
the
the day
after he left
the presidency i flew i was one of the
the small cadre of correspondence who
flew out with him to california got off
the plane and spent the next two years
in the book but actually i had been
doing interviews in this book going back
into the 80s i mean you'd have different
groups of people for instance would
leave the white house at the end of the
first term
i tried to interview them then because i
knew
i knew that
after four or five years they would
remember things differently so i had
done a lot of the interviewing before
but
but i actually wrote it in over a two
year period i started writing in june of
89 and i guess i finished november last
year
948 pages long 24.95 at the bookstore
published by simon schuster
what was your reaction
when right in the middle of your book
coming out the kitty kelly book hit and
got all that publicity well since it's
the same publisher and since the
publisher had said they were going to
publish it in may uh my reaction wasn't
uh
wasn't very uh positive uh
the uh
i guess you're asking me about the
production of this book i i ought to uh
i've already done my anti-cigarette
commercial i would i ought to do the one
positive commercial which is that my
wife mary it did the research for this
book which has 9
1950 notes
and an extensive bibliography
and
it was really a joint project
uh if she hadn't done it uh this book
wouldn't be done and i wouldn't be
sitting here
but back to the other question about
kitty kelly does it does it irritate you
yours is a very serious in-depth look at
ronald reagan
she writes this book that has a lot of
the first of all what was your reaction
to the book well it's hard to get
you know you know i read so many books
and i read the acknowledgements of kitty
kelly's book and it lists me
uh as one of the the the sources the
the implication is that she interviewed
me she said she thanks these people
who shared stories with her i never
shared any story with her i gave a
speech to a group of journalists
uh in in which she came and she tape
recorded the speech
now that's not what we call an interview
and and so
if you have that sort of
fraud at the core
how do you then believe i mean if i were
to do that uh
those sort of things i'd be fired most
people would be you know and uh
so i didn't i didn't take uh
seriously the stories the stories i've
read of course the news accounts of of
the book
you know ronald reagan is a man who uh
when he did the cigarette commercial for
chesterfield
he had they had to paint the cigarette
in now some people have criticized
ronald reagan for taking money for a
product that he didn't use and
particularly a product that
as unhealthy as as that one but
one thing you could be darn sure is that
ronald reagan didn't smoke anything
marijuana tobacco and anybody who knows
him uh
whether they like him or think he's
terrible will tell you the same thing so
i just didn't take the book seriously
and and you have to uh
you have to ask yourself uh
over a period of time
how will how will
that book or this book or other books be
viewed it isn't uh
you know the national enquirer attracts
a lot of attention too
um
that doesn't necessarily mean that
it has historical validity
uh one more question on that and we'll
go back to your book um has it helped or
hurt you
in talking about this man at this time
and i mean have it been a lot of well
the fact that that book came out with a
splash on the front pages of the papers
for all the reasons that it got the
splash uh how has it affected do you
think the the treatment of your book at
this time well i think it's clearly hurt
me in the sense that uh
i'm answering questions as i am now
brian about about her book rather than
than my own and uh
most shows aren't like c-span they don't
have
you know an hour to take to talk about a
subject if you're talking about that
subject and you have
five minutes or three minutes uh 90
seconds can be a long time on television
that's harmful
over a period extended period of time
well we have to see
by the way this is a for our audience
it's a two-hour presentation separated
into two different hours and this is
part one if they've just joined us want
to make sure that they know that because
they're going to see your face on this
network more than normal on a book notes
program let me go back to page 97 of
your book
the source of reagan's inspiration was
less the constitution than the movies
well i i think that's right what does
that mean
well i don't really
what's what's the kind of overall
philosophy of i know it's tough to pick
out
were the movies more important to him
and how he so as you say here played his
role than the constitution was doesn't
mean that he valued hollywood more than
he valued the constitution of the united
states it means that the stories
that that
that he told
and the way he viewed america
was very much based in
hollywood where he had
spent in the title of
great film the best years of
his life
he was
he was grounded in
movie stories movie lore you know
there's many stories in this book
where where
where he
he tells stories which he thinks
happened in
in fact which in fact
happened in a in a movie the famous
story about the
the
b-17 uh
pilot who
who rides the plane down with his
wounded gunner
of various other stories he has this
story
of the uh
from the spanish civil war where where
he
uh we think it's from the spanish civil
war i don't know i ever
uh
pinned it down but the story where
americans come in and the fact that
they're americans is
especially wonderful and he tells the
story he has these images and he's in
his mind's eye of the flags and the
and the bands playing and uh
and i don't think there's anything
particularly sinister in that
uh uh
hollywood when he was
when reagan was a part of it
was a
reflection of american values it was the
lead leading exponent of american mass
culture people went to the movies
in the 1930s in the 1940s
reagan was cast as a
handsome
midwestern hero
playing uh
the heartwarming role to paraphrase gary
wills of himself
i don't think
i don't think it's surprising he was in
hollywood from the time he was 26 years
old
uh to the time he was
in his mid-50s that he would draw
his stories
from
where he lived and from the craft
that he practiced
you write a lot about the either the
three by five or the four by six card
they started out as three by fives and
became four by six why
well i think he i i i'm not sure exactly
i suspect it was more of a function of
his eyesight which wasn't he he had from
the time of his childhood he was
he he had a little problem with the
sight he was nearsighted i don't know
how that affected his
in on the cards but
but he also liked he had a great
developed shorthand
of
where he could compress
almost the whole of a speech this sort
of basic speech he had that was often
just called the speech
and and he would write it out and the
words would i've looked at those cards
in the uh
uh in the hoover archive some of these
early early uh
cards and they
you would see
you would see that he would get almost a
whole speech in the card and i think he
could get more on a
four by six obviously than he could get
on a three by five those cards made a
lot of people mad
i don't think the cards made people mad
i think what
what
upset people
after they got to know him the
congressman are our good example
congressman who had known him
for several years i mean
not their first meeting but who maybe
had been at the white house
a dozen times or the leadership
many more times and here the president
is reading to them
from cards that
that annoyed him because they thought he
should be
talking to them the way we're talking
without notes
and they also felt uh
felt i think that
he was too much a captive of those cards
i i view the cards uh
pretty much
i think don regan said that in the book
but other people have said it to me
they were a device for him they were a
comfort mechanism for him they were like
uh
[Music]
a cane is for some people or
or some prop that somebody uses that
they feel comfortable with they were
they were security for him
i think
i think he overused them particularly in
the last years of his presidency on the
other hand
i've seen reagan very effective without
notes and
uh i don't know if i tell the story in
this book or in my last one but i
remember one time i think it was in
florida where the uh
there was speaking outdoors and the wind
came up and it
blew all the cards around you know so
he's he has to pick him up and they're
all in different order and reagan who
had a good
self
deprecating sense of humor said
it doesn't really matter what order
these are in anyway
and just and essentially gave the speech
without his cards
if you had to list the three or four
main defining moments in his presidency
what would it be
i think
[Music]
one of them
was clearly the assassination attempt
because
this occurs uh
on march 30th he's like
40 days
into his presidency
and
all at once he's
he's he's wounded
and and
america sees this
rather gallant man quipping
telling stories using one-liners
that that would
would have seemed
i think artificial in many circumstances
except this is a person
who could have died from this wound we
we found out later that those was missed
this aorta by you know this much i mean
it was a very very serious wound
and doctors have told me that many
people never really recover
fully from gunshot wounds and here this
man is
you know
well advanced in life at this point he's
he's he's just had his 70th birthday and
he bounces back in a hurry but i think
that he became
a mythic
figure
in in in america that when he was
making the quipping you know i hope that
to the doctors i hope you're all
republicans in those kind of lines i
think that was a defining defining
moment in his in his presidency
i think
um
i think that another
another moment that was uh
very important to him
was when
congress i don't remember what the day
that was but when congress finally got
these tax and
and budget bills passed in that first
year of his presidency
uh dick worthlin who was his pollster
and had done a lot of polls showed that
what people particularly liked about
reagan
uh was that
that he was getting stuff through
congress and
there had been a long period where
congress and the presidency had been
stalemated most americans are not
partisans they don't they like to see
their government work
and here paradoxically under a person
who denounced government the government
the government seemed to be to be
working there are a lot of other
moments in the reagan presidency uh
that are worth something if i could uh
i'll just give you two or three which
are which are quite removed from the one
is is uh
him standing in berlin in front of that
wall and saying mr gorbachev tear down
that wall which is a speech that still
kind of gives me a
a kind of a goosebump when i hear it
another another was ronald reagan in red
square
with uh where it seemed to me the mere
fact of him being in red square him and
gorbachev walking together even though
they both had
their own propaganda impulses of this
meeting
uh
was a signal to the to the to the world
hey this cold war is really over and
another in a darker one i think was
ronald reagan in that speech he gave in
november
of 86 to the uh soon after the uh
midterm elections where he's explaining
what happened
uh or thinks he is in the iran contra
affair and he is so unbelievable i mean
he's telling stories that turn out to be
totally untrue
and and you see a different kind of
ronald reagan who people always believe
reagan he's telling these stories
and he's essentially unbelievable as
every poll said you know people
first people who had always trusted
reagan said hey this guy is lying to me
and they never that was a new experience
for ronald reagan not not being
criticized i mean he took many positions
that
the majority of americans didn't agree
with the contras for one there was never
a poll that showed a majority of
americans
supported the contras
that's fine i mean
you can you go through life and you're
disagreed with but people believed
reagan and that whole period there was
another news conference right after that
i remember the speech which i thought
was
i was actually
in my hometown of of reno when that
speech was was given
for a reason i don't remember and uh but
i remember watching that speech on
television
and and and and saying i've never seen
him look that bad
um let me ask you about some other
incidents and i know you're right about
a bunch of pittsburgh how'd that happen
well bitburg was a
demonstration of a lot of a lot of
elements in the reagan administration
that that that were important to him you
know i wrote the story that i wrote that
caused the most
anxiety among
the reagan staff of any story i ever
wrote about reagan as governor president
or a campaigner was the story where he
had told
at two different times
uh how he had
photographed
nazi death camps after world war ii of
course he'd not been out of the country
during world war ii and he told one of
these stories to
simon wiesenthal the famed nazi hunter
and he told it again to yitzhak schmear
now they denied to this day reagan wrote
me a letter jim baker called me all
these people but the fact is you have
two highly intelligent people and these
two stories occurred five months apart
it took me a long time it was well after
the event
uh
when when i heard when i heard about it
and longer than that when i was able to
prove it and i think it's statistically
remote that that he the two people who
who were in totally different meetings
would remember this
these stories i i go back to that
because
i don't think that ronald reagan
was consciously
lying when he said those things i think
he was caught up in his story and he
actually impressed shamir particularly
so deeply that he cared so much about
the holocaust now i think reagan did
care about the holocaust i think that
that that there's nobody who's occupied
that office who felt more deeply
that that the world had abandoned the
jews
he had seen he had seen newsreels that's
what he had confused
when he was uh
was in the in the
what was then the army air corps at the
uh during world war ii
uh the the newsreels of the
uh the camps after the allies uh had
liberated them and he was
that was a living sort of of a member of
memory to him if you can have a memory
of something that you have not
experienced
i think that most people who talk to him
about the holocaust knew how deeply he
felt about it
and i think for him to agree
to bittberg
in a way
cast appall over his presidency that is
particularly unfortunate for this
president who didn't
who who felt so deeply about about the
sufferings of the jew of the jewish
people in the event let me just in the
event that that uh some of our audience
have never heard of the bitburg story
can you just give us a brief well what
basically happened is that that
helmut cole the
west german
chancellor asked
who had been who had attended some
reconciliation ceremony but
french german reconciliation ceremony
with meteoron at a cemetery where
where the world war one french and
german dead were both buried ask him to
come to germany and celebrate
a similar event uh
with
german soldiers and were in a cemetery
where german soldiers and american
soldiers were buried from world war ii
the problem was that there weren't any
such summer cemeteries they were
buried separately and in all of the
german cemeteries there were also
not just soldiers from the german army
the vermont there were also ss
soldiers and that was done deliberately
because they'd scattered the ss soldiers
around so there wouldn't be uh
some one cemetery that was just uh just
of the ss
and so reagan wound up sort of casually
agreeing to to go
to germany for a similar ceremony where
there couldn't
be a similar ceremony and he wound up
showing up at the cemetery which had
been a
tank staging area for the battle of the
bulge and in which there were
ss soldiers who had uh some of whom had
murdered americans
uh uh uh you know were were being
honored now reagan
could have gotten out of it
uh he would have gotten out of it if
he'd if he probably had a more skillful
chief of staff than don regan
but he's a stubborn man he had agreed to
go to bitburg and he had agreed with
cole and once reagan gives you his word
he tries to keep his word i mean he
wound up
many black people in this country think
that ronald reagan signaled uh that he
was a racist because he started his 80
campaign
by going going to
neshoba mississippi which is where
there's a it's a mississippi state fair
but it's also where three civil rights
workers were killed
reagan
went there because he'd given trent lott
then a congressman and now senator from
mississippi his word that he would go
he didn't go there because he wanted to
advertise
uh that he identified with the the
darkest elements in in
mississippi's uh history but he
but he he would never sort of of uh he
said on that occasion in fact to his
pollster he said that that you should
something about once you've made a
booking you know you shouldn't
you shouldn't cancel it or something and
that was the same thing that was at play
with in bitburg he was he had told cole
he would go
sometimes ronald reagan could see the
big picture better than anybody in the
world that he could see
a distance you know he could see across
the room uh other times he he he he
couldn't see at all and and to not
go back on what was a promise that he
was going to visit you
he would do something that sent the
wrong signal now
no bitburg story i think should be
complete without saying the same day he
laid this wreath in
pittsburgh
it's the most uncomfortable ceremony by
that time for ronald reagan and
everybody else nancy reagan had not
wanted him to go and
most of his a lot of his staff people
hadn't wanted to go that he also spoke
at bergen belson giving one of the most
moving tributes
to the victims of the holocaust that uh
has ever been given by uh by any
american political leader certainly so
it was not uh
you you often saw this
the worst and as tip o'neill said on
another day where
where uh when the challenger had had
gone down
and uh
tip had had a big quarrel with him that
morning in front of a lot of other
congressmen because reagan had started
in about how some of the unemployed were
people who didn't want to work and tip
got angry and said you know that's
you've been telling that story for years
i'm talking about people who were thrown
out of work you know by
in the steel mills they're not welfare
cheats
and then the next later in the day they
had the challenger disaster and reagan
gave that speech and tip o'neill
wrote that he'd seen the best and worst
of ronald reagan in one day i think that
was true i think that was also true the
day of bitburg and i think you often did
see
ronald reagan
best and worse close together and i
think that ronald reagan's gifts
often rescued reagan from himself as
they did on this particular day
lou kennan the book president reagan the
role of a lifetime is one of many books
that have been written about this man as
you know because you talk a lot in your
book about other books oh i do
um
how come you did that so much you
mentioned the george will books or the
columns and you talked a lot about gary
wills and
bill niskanen and many others martin
anderson because i think that
one of the
duties of a biographer
is to examine the
the record to examine the
contemporaneous record part of that
record is in is in
the books
the so-called kiss and tell books i uh
i like ken adelman who wrote a very good
book about that administration i like
his phrase of kick and tell
even better
uh and uh
there is in uh books by david stockman
and by
by don regan in this canon and
especially i would say by by marty
anderson there there there there's a lot
of of of uh rich material
from people who either
either uh
had felt close to reagan and were
estranged from him or as was the case in
stockman and regan or who were
remain essentially uh loyal to him as is
the case with with anderson
i think that reagan
did not inspire
the kind of lasting loyalty
from
people that some presidents did there
are obvious exceptions to that you
started this program by quoting from
lynn noffsinger and lynn nofsinger is
is a conspicuous exception to that
but
reagan kept himself to himself
on one level
he was always the most mannerly and
courteous
of men
he treated people well the people who
worked for him the secretaries the
people who guarded him
he was never imperious he never threw
his weight around he was never
demanding
but
but he also didn't give of himself he
kept
a part of his different people who
worked for him have described it was
like he'd seen so many
different
directors different been in different
cast it was been in so many movies that
it was like he didn't form lasting
attachments i think marty anderson among
others have said that when he left and
came back after he was sort of forced
aside in a
political
power struggle and return and it was
like reagan didn't know
that they'd been gone
so unless you
had a lot of self-security of
on your own unless you had a lot of kind
of
confidence in yourself and and didn't
need
uh the approval of the sun king here
you became after a while uh disenchanted
and what you see running through these
books these these these kiss and tell
books is
is is a sort of a disenchantment with
reagan
uh because
i think
partly because the people involved never
really felt
that they
that he took them
to him you know somebody said to me just
the other day he asked me did i
like reagan i said yeah i liked him well
enough and he said this person said to
me he knows reagan very well said i
don't dislike him but he says to like
somebody you have to
he has to be a person who extends to you
some kind of friendship and reagan
didn't do that he was the friend of the
american people
he had a bond with the people
but
but up close
up close
if you formed an attachment to reagan it
was often it was often one way
and that was harder for for some of
these personalities it's often said that
they wrote all these books just because
there's so much money you know that they
got such huge sums i'm sure that has
that has something to do with it in the
case of some of the books but i don't
think that that's the
the real the real uh
story i think the real story is that
they didn't
they didn't feel the kind of loyalty
that you often see i mean that uh
uh
people is
lyndon johnson richard nixon
jimmy carter you know different produced
a kind of a personal
personal loyalty personal attachment of
people that that
with some conspicuous exceptions didn't
last in the reagan in the reagan case
this sounds like a leading question but
uh
i don't think it is um
anybody else in the united states follow
ronald reagan as closely as you
i don't know the answer to that question
there are a lot of reporters who
followed reagan for a very very long
time
you know one that comes to mind is my
friend george skelton at the los angeles
times
i don't think there's
been anybody
who kind of
set out to
define him at different stages of his
career as i did and i never really
i mean it would be great to say that i
saw all this that in
the late 60s but but i didn't understand
ronald reagan when i and i wanted to
write about him and i thought that
writing about him and jess unruh was a
wonderful way to
you could do a dual biography
and then as he continued in public life
i still felt i didn't understand him so
i never i call this book an unintended
the third book in an unintended trilogy
and that's really right i never set out
to write three books about him
but i found
that that
there was more to ronald reagan than the
surface that beneath the surface you had
a rather complicated
character and
a guy who who wasn't quite what
either his fans or his critics thought
he was he was
he was a little
he was a little sharper than his critics
thought he knew more he saw further
but he had great gaps in his knowledge
and
and great lapses that his fans didn't
see
and my
effort in these books and particularly
this book is to try to
to get beyond this and get some kind of
a coherent
coherent whole and i think that the
reason there that i'm
unique in this if i am is that once i
got started i just
i i couldn't stop because i didn't think
i had i had really done the job
even though both of my first two books
were very well reviewed and i felt good
about those books
i i felt there was still more to ronald
reagan that i wanted to tell
lots of uh people that were around him
were written about in that book
of all those people that you remember
who had the most impact on him
besides his wife
probably mike deaver
i think mike deaver had as much impact
on reagan because he understood him in
personal terms it was often said that
that mike mike deaver was like a son to
reagan well reagan
kind of distant with his son sometimes
too but but but i think uh
i think deever who was sort of dismissed
in this town it's odd that i'd use that
word because dever was considered to be
a media meister it was often said but i
think he was dismissed as a
as a sort of a
glorified valet
you know to to reagan i mean sort of the
retainer
but i think he actually
had influence on him and got very close
to him and understood reagan he
certainly understood nancy but i think
there were also issues we didn't know
about that until diva wrote his own book
of
like the bombing of beirut which which
outraged reagan and which outraged
deiver and i think deeper was
influential with him i don't
i think that a lot of different people
were influential with reagan however in
their own specialties because reagan
tended to
rely i would argue too much
on
experts in some areas i think george
schultz was influential with him on some
things cap weinberger was certainly
influential with him ed meese
um
jim baker even though baker wasn't as
close to reagan personally as these
other people
um i i mean i it's hard to just say uh
here is one person that there is no
there's no harry hopkins uh who was
fdr's great advisor there's no harry
hopkins in the in the reagan
administration which feud
was the most interesting to you like the
schultz weinberger or the
schultz and weinberger by far because
these were two
people of genuine
accomplishment
they both had reagan's ear
and they were both distrusted by
different groups of
of people within the reagan
administration reagan once quipped it uh
at a gridiron dinner i think it was that
the trouble with his administration is
that the right the sometimes the right
hand doesn't know what the far right
hand is doing and there was a lot too
there was a lot of uh
of uh truth to that jest uh there were
the uh people who considered themselves
the militant guardians of the
conservative flame you know thought that
people like george schultz and jim baker
who would by any
standard of of uh
normal political measurement be quite
con considered quite conservative where
we're dangerously moderate or liberal
and the moderates the pragmatists as
they were often called during the reagan
administration many of them uh
uh thought that uh that the you know
right wingers as they called them you
know were sort of uh raving dangerous uh
people
so you had
in this context
you had weinberger and schultz
who didn't like each other went way back
a lot of people think it goes back to
their bechtel it goes back before that
according to frank carlucci who worked
with both of them to when they were both
in the
office of budget which it then was in
the in the nixon administration they had
a personal dislike they were just
temperamentally
opposite i mean
capsule a a lawyer who
who is adversarial george is a economics
professor and
and the significance of their feud
within the reagan administration
went way beyond their personalities they
were often on opposite sides of the
fence and they were successful in
blocking the advocacies of others
reagan's great fault i think as a
president
was his which goes back to his childhood
of wanting harmony of this situation i
think where he did have
a home with an alcoholic father reagan
craved harmony he didn't like disharmony
if you and i were arguing together and
we were on equal footing which
weinberger and schultz were
reagan would want
to give each of us something he wouldn't
want the dispute to end
with you winning or me winning and so
the conflict between charleston
weinberger produced
frequently a sort of paralysis within
the reagan administration we're going to
talk a lot more about people in the
second part of this two-part series but
i want to show our audience the book
our guest has been lou cannon
author of president reagan the role of a
lifetime thank you for joining us
former president's interview with ronald
reagan biographer lou cannon this is an
hour
lou cannon author of president reagan
the role of a lifetime
on page 231
you quote paul laxalt former senator
from nevada
is saying this about ronald reagan
he's a loner he's a loner even in his
relationship with his god
and the same way unfortunately with his
kids why did you pick that quote
well of course i thought it was true
i i think that uh
that ronald reagan keeps
his distance
and that i think i i like the uh
part about even in his relationship with
his
god because i think ronald reagan is
quite religious in a very personal way
he's not uh
he's not particularly
uh
enamored of organized religion despite
the show of that from the white house he
he but but he is he is a uh
he's a believer
and uh uh
and i think paul axalt who knows him
very very well realizes that as far as
the kids are concerned
um
i quote
all of the children
in this book either from
things they've written or from
interviews i've done
all of who sort of say in their own
different ways that they don't really
really quite
know their father there's a sort of
particularly poignant story from
michael reagan's book about how
reagan arrives at i think it's his prep
school graduation in arizona and
introduces himself and says i'm
ronald reagan and he says i'm your you
know i'm your son michael
uh that's the sort of uh
i know he was wearing a mortar board and
stuff but
still lou cannon you're still a reporter
with the washington post yes i'm western
correspondent for the post now and
based in california and uh
enjoying it very much thank you how long
have you been with the post i've been
with the post since 1970
how does the
world look from california now that you
you're back there after you spent all
this time in washington
well
more interesting i guess i i
i loved working in washington
it was one of the great it was it was a
i i i maybe sound a little corny about
it but i think
that uh
to be able to cover the white house for
the washington post is is a privilege
and i really enjoyed it but what i
didn't enjoy was
being
a slave to whoever was the president you
know you don't have a moment
when when you when your schedule is
dependent on anything other than the
president's schedule and you also
there's a hot house atmosphere that
flourishes
reporters within the white house there's
there's too many of us and there's
you know too few of them and
it's very nice to be
to be
back where you're writing about
farmers and droughts and people who are
coming in to make a new life for
themselves in america
california's exciting state you know
it's nearly one of
eight americans live there by the
turn of the century uh everybody in the
state will be a minority i i find it
great i don't think
a person should do the same thing in
life all the time and
it's it's it's it's wonderful to be back
there one of the things that you write
often in this book i don't know how
often but i noticed i noticed it more
than once is that ronald reagan
supposedly didn't care much about
washington and he was looking forward to
going back home to his california is
that well that's true of
i don't know if it's true
always as much as as as he thought it
was true but what
ronald reagan liked washington you know
he didn't i also write in that book that
all that he campaigned
against washington politically as carter
had done he adjusted to the
social life of the city you know much
much better and uh
but what ronald reagan likes is
another one of these paradoxes of him he
likes both the spotlight
and he likes solitary time he likes
feeling he liked the ranch a lot in
california because
he could get away and
all the secret service were up there
there it wasn't obtrusive you know and
he could have the feeling that he was he
was he was by himself he told me after
he came back to uh to uh california that
i interviewed him for his
80th birthday for a
piece in the post that uh
what he missed was camp david he said he
didn't miss the
i don't ronald reagan did not was not
power mad uh he was he also said that he
was able to he knew when there was time
to leave the stage and he was able to
walk away from the white house and i
don't think that
uh
drove him
crazier that he even particularly
bothered him
but i think the he felt as he says at
one point in there that kind of cooped
up like he was in a cage in the white
house and uh
and all the more so after the
assassination attempt i mean obviously
there was a high degree of security but
he loved camp david and he does miss
camp david and he said that before
but i think he was very
i think that one of the qualities about
ronald reagan that was
on the whole a
positive quality about him was that he
he he was he he became president in
order he wanted to accomplish certain
things
he didn't become president just to
to be the most powerful man in the world
and and he was able he knew he knew
himself enough
that he was able to
walk away from it when the time was over
and and be happy with himself
you um in our other interview you said
that you've probably interviewed him 40
times in your life um that's
conservative conservative including
those 40 times and possibly others
what's your favorite personal moment
with
this man and
why
um
i don't know um
i don't know
favorite is is
is the
okay let me just jump in to ask you
though about one moment that i remember
is when he called you after your mother
died well that's the moment i was
thinking and i don't think anybody would
use the word
favorite that's why i was i was balking
on it yes he he did call me and uh
my mother had been sick a long time
before she died and uh
when he called me
i i thought as you do
that i've been prepared for death and
like most of us uh you know i wasn't
and i said that to him i thanked him for
calling me and i said
i thought i was prepared you know for
this and
and he said you're never prepared for
the death of your mother
uh now ronald reagan's mother is the
most important person to him i mean he's
influenced by his mother but i thought
that was such a wise
comforting thing to say it didn't have
any
he may have called me because somebody
told him to call me and his opening
words may have been a script but he
didn't know what i was going to say that
wasn't
that wasn't from a script that was from
from his heart and it was also it was
also
wise but i don't that's not part of an
interview you know that's kind of a
personal
personal thing i guess
the favorite moment that i ever had uh
in a
in an interview
was
was probably
was also personal but was personal about
him
uh where he was talking about what had
happened
and i never heard the story whether it's
an interview for this book we were
talking about his father and
and and ronald reagan like a lot of us
he's you know romanticizes his boyhood i
mean he it's a ideal everything was
wonderful you know
uh but he he was talking about the
alcoholism of his dad's drinking and he
told of a time when he when he by this
time reagan was a young man working as a
sports announcer in des moines i think
and uh
his father apparently had been drinking
kind of heavily his mother visited him
regularly and reagan wrote him a letter
this is what reagan told me he wrote his
father a letter and said that
he wanted him to stop drinking because
he ronald reagan had this problem too
and reagan said this was a lie this is
the only time by the way and all the
time that i know ray reagan who has this
marvelous ability to tell something that
is factually not true and make himself
believe it's the truth this is the only
time that i
that i've had personal experience where
ronald reagan said
yes i told a lie and the fact that
ronald reagan is not comfortable with
lying is that he remembered this
what some
going on 60 years later and it still
troubled him it troubled him that he did
it you know and i that's a fairly it's a
noble lie it seems to me if if there is
such a thing i mean he was certainly he
was saying it to get his father to stop
drinking he wasn't
uh and his father never replied and he
never
knew what
impact if any that that that had on him
and i and i was
and the reason that that sticks with me
is that ronald reagan rarely told you
anything about himself ronald reagan was
a great frustration to most of the
people who interviewed him most of the
time because he would tell you a story
that you'd heard a hundred times and he
would tell you that story as if he told
as he was telling you for the first time
and even though he told it to you before
and it was very hard it was very hard to
get to get inside of him so the moments
that were satisfying and interviewing
reagan or interesting and it was when he
told you
something about
his personal life or his value system he
told
i was very interested in the stories he
had to tell about armageddon because he
believed in armageddon literally i mean
he took it as a biblical prophecy but he
somehow wanted to avert it you know
which was the
which was part of the story of the
strategic defense initiative or star
wars he saw it as the
foretelling of nuclear war which he
thought he ought to
avert
i don't know anybody who's quite
got it that way i mean most people who
think who believe in a biblical prophecy
literally think it's going to happen you
know and there isn't anything that they
can do about it
a lot of people don't believe in it a
lot of people think it's an allegory i
don't know anybody else who believes in
it but thinks that he can do something
to stop it
you um
you've written three books on ronald
reagan
uh you for how many years would you say
that uh as far as ronald reagan was
concerned you were writing about him in
other words you following his every
moment how many years in the state house
in california how many years in
washington well i covered all of his
campaigns and i covered i guess most of
his first
most of his first governorship and then
i came to to washington when he was
governor in his second term but i went
back to cover the camp paying for
reelection in 70. i covered his campaign
for the presidency in 68 and 76 and 80
and
84. and then i covered him uh
periodically in the 70s i mean i covered
the white house when he ran against
president ford i spent about half the
time with the ford people and half the
time with him
but then starting in november 1979 when
he announced i covered ronald reagan
continuously until the literally the day
he left office i covered his entire 80
campaign i covered the entire
eight years of the presidency is there
anybody that wouldn't talk to you for
this book
there are a handful of people uh
uh
i don't
frankly uh
desire to to name them because there's
only we're only talking about uh
uh
six or seven uh people
out of uh
you know several hundred uh i will name
one that i think had a particularly good
reason not to talk to me uh
that was john poindexter now i had
interviewed poindexter however when he
was the national security advisor in the
white house so i knew him and i didn't
just know him from
from television or or stories but of
course mr poindexter was facing
of
felony charges for which he was
convicted and which are now under appeal
and
i thought he had a pretty good reason
not wanting to be interviewed
but
basically with very very few few
exceptions with a handful of exceptions
uh
the people who who worked for ronald
reagan
sat down to be interviewed i interviewed
his
all of his national security advisers
for this book for instance except
poindexter all all five of them
all of his four chiefs of staff his
secretaries of defense and state
uh
ed meese and his late
uh william frank smith his predecessors
attorney general so i think i i
interviewed all of the
the major figures with very few
exceptions in the reagan administration
and a lot of the
a lot of the minor figures as well
we've often seen people refer to wait
till lou cannon's book comes out we'll
see the definitive reagan they also
write wait till edmond morris's book
comes out we'll see something else what
will be the difference between what you
did and what edmond morris is doing i
haven't a clue brian i mean
i think everybody's got to write their
own book i i i hope
that people will find that this is a
definitive
work of of uh about ronald reagan uh mr
morris a
distinguished biographer of theodore
roosevelt i'm sure he'll uh
he'll have his own
look at it i mean all of us
there's no last word on a president i
mean
people write
even about the presidents who are most
written about abraham lincoln
franklin roosevelt new books come out
almost every year so
if anybody
if anybody is
so full of self-delusion that they think
that they
they're going to do the last word on any
subject they should do something other
than be a biographer or historian
that doesn't bother me or or even really
interest me what interested me is that i
i had a look at reagan over an extended
period of time i'd written a lot of
stories about i wrote hundreds and
hundreds of stories about it i'd seen
him in different settings
a lot of these people ronald reagan is
80 years old a lot of the people who
work for him are in the 70s the reagan
archives are going to be
open you know a lot of these archives
will be open 20 years from now most of
these people will be gone i know ronald
reagan and his administration well
enough to know that a lot of these
stories aren't in the archives anyway
because a lot of what happened with
reagan didn't happen with what was
written down the written record
reagan sometimes didn't read it he
didn't know about it
reagan was a between pers he was what
happened was between him and people
and so it seemed to me very valuable
to get
this history down
while the people
were alive and close to it and i'm sure
that 50 years from now there's going to
be a whole
look at different look at reagan and
everybody else but
but i hope that that this book
because it has the living recollections
of people when they were close to this
process
will be of help to those those
historians who are writing long after
after i and dad let alone these people
who are
far older than me who work for ronald
reagan there's a may 5th 1989 quote from
nancy reagan i assume it's from an
interview that you did with her
uh you have to see my my wife's good
notes because if it's noted what uh i'll
read it
he assigns to everyone else his own
makeup yes that's from an interview with
nancy reagan what did she mean by that
she meant i think that reagan
reagan
could not conceive
of being
duplicitous
that reagan reagan reagan tells you what
what he thinks that's the way nancy sees
him and ronald reagan
doesn't
the idea that somebody would sit there
and tell you
tell you something
that he didn't believe in order to
advance himself with ronald reagan in
order to get a job or promotion within
the white house in order to
get somebody else demoted or fired or
hurt
since ronald reagan wouldn't do these
things he doesn't
see to it that other people
would do these things ronald reagan was
gullible
frequently in dealing with people nancy
reagan observed this about him she's not
unique in observing it about him but she
she's the closest to him of anybody on
earth so she sought
she saw it the most and i think she she
felt it the
the most keenly and she felt that he
needed protection from people who
pretended to share his agenda or his
objectives and in fact
did him harm
that's what she means by it
people
people that were around him um as a way
of getting you to explain let me tell
you a story that happened to us and so
you can
put the pieces together you know i've
never talked about this this um
but i can't remember the i think it was
1983 we got a call from joe holmes
you remember joe hope i remember well
who was he how did he fit in joe was a
sort of a
character who
who believed very much that there would
be a video record of reagan he wanted to
uh
he wanted to make sure that there was
every that that reagan's meetings were
all preserved
not just
with still pictures but that there be an
actual
kind of camera record of of of reagan
and he was a
he was a
kind of an old pr guy and
not a lot of anymore no no no joe passed
away several years ago uh
um i liked him i thought he was a good
guy californian yeah okay the reason i
bring it up is because he
he called and said
we want to do some programs with high
school kids
the president does
now then he said
the president wants to do this but a
couple of his age right around him don't
and what we want to do is just put the
president in a room
turn the camera on and let these kids at
random asking questions
and and i get i tell the story as a way
to get into the trioka
he said that troy case excuse me
the three people were jim baker mike
dever and ed miese
and joe holmes said
jim baker and mike deaver don't want him
to do these programs even though he
wants to do them but ed meese does
eventually we ended up doing five
programs with him in the white house
with 45 high school students asking him
questions at random
now what is that all about why were the
two not wanting to do it and the one and
joe holmes working through the edmy side
of that troika
well i don't know since i don't know
this story i don't know why in this
particular case
uh or you know if that was in fact the
lineup or if
i mean i i i don't portray as yeah but
we can talk about it generally without i
i don't
i wouldn't
say why somebody wanted to to do
something unless i'd done the reporting
on the story
let me tell you just a little more so as
a way of of uh getting you to to fill in
the blanks
the explanation was that this is too
random
and too chancy and we don't know what
those kids are going to ask but the
president wants to meet with kids well
that sort of sounds right to me i mean
the way
you're
it sounds to me
as if joe was probably giving you the
correct lineup
basically
deever and baker
were
often worried that reagan would say
something
uh they'd seen a lot of examples of it
where he where he talked
off
his script or where he just would say
what came into his head and get into
trouble for it i mean there were a lot
of examples the one that comes to mind
during the campaign
of 80 was that
he went to some conference a religious
conference and a religious
broadcaster asked him about uh
creationism and reagan said uh
well maybe they could teach both you
know they could teach evolution and
creation and
i don't know
i don't want to i know that's an
explosive subject for your your viewers
and i
i raise it only because
reagan just was sort of offhandedly
saying what
what occurred to him and it created a
huge
furor you know that reagan didn't
believe in evolution and i think
more was made of it than
more was made of the reply probably than
was warranted but
you never knew what reagan was going to
pop out of reagan you never knew what
would come out out of him and uh
if if you were trying to
run a campaign for something in the
early reagan years i don't know uh
83 i'm not i'm not sure but
but
but the
what they were trying to do in the white
house with baker and dever particularly
were trying to do
was to keep the focus on
the economic program i tell there in
some length a story about how
how they all came down very hard on al
haig
uh
originally when he wanted to put out
some white paper i think it was a
nicaragua because they didn't want to i
don't remember was nicaragua or
el salvador but they didn't want to get
the the story focused off
the economic program the the people who
were managing in the white house tried
very much
to to get a particular theme
and stay with it and they knew that if
they just turned reagan loose that he
would
talk about anything that came up and
pretty soon the white house would be
enmeshed in some
uh
extraneous or ancillary controversy that
had nothing to do with what they were
trying to
uh
to emphasize and often with what reagan
was trying to emphasize uh i think that
ed meese
uh
it's it
it's odd because
in some ways
i i think i say this in there in some
ways the
the uh
the conservatives tended to overrate him
uh overrate his abilities they they and
the
the the people who were the more
pragmatic faction tend to underrate
his ability but but they all really at
some level agreed that you just couldn't
turn ronald reagan loose
uh you'd have to know in any given
controversy
what had gone on between them to know
why
miese was on the side of letting reagan
speak i think that in fairness to add
that that nice more than any of the
other
people from because he had seen him in
california where he had been his chief
of staff although he had another title
for for it but that what he had been his
chief of staff in california that that
ed knew
that reagan is particularly good with
young people i think i don't know how
your programs turned out but i always
found those absolutely more interesting
than just about anything else reagan did
because
because reagan really tried to answer
the the questions and and
my guess is you'd have to put that to
meis but my guess is that me thought
that
the advantage of seeing reagan in that
setting naturally talking to kids
outweighed the disadvantage of him
of him saying some comment that the
white house had to explain for the next
three days on the other hand it wasn't
usually niece who had to do the
explaining
there were a lot of controversies
between
those three people and other people in
the white house
that
didn't really withstand close analysis
often they they got by 83 they were in
such conflict
that oftentimes
something that nice wanted to do the
baker faction opposed because it was mis
advocating it and vice versa i mean i i
often times the conflict was not based
upon
a different perception of ronald reagan
as it was
on a power struggle in the white house
that went on
reagan oblivious to it reagan just just
never paid any attention to these
conflicts on his staff
and that allowed them to rage you
couldn't imagine that going on in the
bush white house i mean bush
bush is so
uh uh it seems to me obsessive about
having a single line come out of the
white house that he calls people up he
has him not talk to reporters he insists
maybe he's reacting what he saw go on in
the reagan white house but reagan never
took any action against this reagan
would complain about leaks and stuff but
the leakers were all around him you know
he never uh he never banged heads so
i i i'm not sure you know without
knowing more about this story that that
it represented a perceptional difference
of reagan or whether it was just the
difference between these two guys on a
particular day well joe holmes kept
telling us in the
you know as they as we led up to doing
the first program i can't get a decision
i've talked to the president out at the
ranch when i'm there with him on the
weekends but
the others are preventing this from
happening well eventually they happen
then what happened i'd like to ask you
about is then then after the program was
over we brought the kids back to the
studio right where you're sitting
did a call-in show and all of a sudden
out of nowhere ronald reagan calls the
call-in show
he says i'm here in my family quarters
watching this program with the kids and
i couldn't help but hearing what uh they
were saying i wanted to call up and
correct this and gave us the distinct
impression that the age weren't there to
tell him he couldn't call he just picked
up the phone dialed away and here he was
oh yeah that's really that that part of
the story uh
really rings true i mean reagan
reagan would uh call up columnist he'd
call up reporters you know he called
me up a couple of times to complain you
know he'd call up people and say i liked
your column or i didn't like your story
i mean you know he'd call up uh
david broder who'd made
the point that many of us made that i
made in an earlier program of yours
about how
how uh
reagan lowering taxes and uh
uh raising the military budget made it
impossible for him to uh
balance the budget or that he hadn't
himself submitted balanced budgets and
said oh no no i i you know i did submit
balanced budgets which of course he had
not
but reagan was uh
used to sort of i think
well he told me once about fan mail he
paid a lot of attention to fan mail you
know when he was in hollywood and i
think that that this was sort of his his
fan mail and he paid he watched
television he read the newspapers one of
the things that reagan did
and you know the expression on a
ball field of a player who you get you
razz and
and he and you get on him and he hears
you and they say he has rabbit ears
reagan had rabbit ears sometimes too i
mean he'd see something that he thought
was unfair
uh you know a documentary on television
bill moyer's famous documentary but
others that that that that held him the
blame for uh the hardship of people and
he'd call up
i mean he didn't
my guess is is that uh
if his age hadn't been more
interfering with him or more protective
of him that he would have done that a
lot more than he did and he did it
fairly frequently
how did you
write this book physically did you write
it in california great difficulty no i
wrote it in a uh
in a uh in the uh
basement in my bunker of a home in uh
oakton uh california most of oakton
virginia uh with my uh
my wife doing the bulk of the research
and
and i finished it
finished it
again with mary's help i finished it in
california in summerlin which is right
near santa barbara i wrote the last
chapter
and some of the
things like the acknowledgements and out
there but
most of the
work was done the same place i lived
where i was when i was covering the
white house and
most of the people you know everybody
said they were going to go to california
on the next on the first plane on the
reagan administration out well
ronald reagan did
george schultz did but
more of them didn't
a lot of people who are always going to
leave i can't wait to get back to
california and i suppose that's true in
other administrations that too we all
know people who couldn't wait to get
back to georgia or texas or
massachusetts who stayed in washington
the rest of their lives that was true
for a lot of the reagan people in the
acknowledgements uh you mentioned
several people and i just want to bring
them up to ask you what involvement they
had
with the book you start out by saying
six friends of considerable professional
accomplishment read the book in
manuscript you name david broder peter
silberman
uh let's see william lee miller bill
plant don oberdorfer
and my eldest son carl cannon who our
audience knows from appearing on many of
our call-in shows why did you pick those
folks to
be your readers well because they won't
care enough about me i guess to wade
through these pages to start with but
they all have a different a different
perspective
bill plant had covered the white house
for
and he has a television perspective
david broder is
in my view and in the view of many other
people the best political correspondent
that ever there was you know and he's
he's been and he's a good friend and
i've been kind enough to read my other
books uh pete silverman in addition to
being uh
my my dear friend
for all these years was my editor at the
washington post and he has a
he's a good eye for things that are uh
that are
that are off don oberdorfer uh is a
has a particular
expertise in foreign policy another good
friend carl was the youngest of my
readers he's he's not only a heck of a
political
writer and and uh and my oldest son but
he's a good friend and and the stuff on
aids and on well and on
inner cities and stuff he had a little
he had a little different touch and
william lee miller who is a very
distinguished professor at
university of virginia and wrote a i
think a most wonderful book on carter
called yankee from georgia
has
has been reading my books for a long
time
struggling with my grammar and syntax
and
and i think you need a
reader who has an academic
background as well as readers who have
backgrounds in journalism so
but the central thing was all of these
people were willing to struggle struggle
through this book that's that's the real
the other reader was my wife mary who
made many valuable editing suggestions
and uh
and then to whom this book is dedicated
the best thing that someone can say
about it
that it's
it tells them about how reagan
was in the presidency
tells them honestly
that the book is the book is true that
it's that it's that it's
it tells you
tells you
what happened and what reagan was like
that's what i want people
to say about it if
if that's what they think about it i
want to ask you about people all those
folks that worked around him
we talked a little bit in the last part
one about the weinberger schultz
relationship what about the weinberger
mcfarland relationship that's looked
like according to you was this nasty
thing
it was poisonous and harmful to both men
weinberger
uh thought that uh mcfarland was an
upstart
completely over his head
and weinberger who who never
frankly capped who i respect in many
ways i i should say that i give him a
lot of credit in this book for opposing
the involvement in lebanon which schultz
and mcfarland favorite i think
weinberger was right on that but i think
weinberg was wrong in a lot of other
things including the the u.s soviet
relationship and he
weinberg had been very close to to bill
clark who was mcfarland's
predecessor and who i've known a long
time and who i think was very
influential in reagan
and
he was he was a national security
advisor when bill left to
become the secretary of interior uh
replacing jim watt
uh mcweinberger uh had not wanted
mcfarland whom he had clashed with in
the past and he made
he made mcfarland the scapegoat for
everything
that happened wrong in the white house
and one in one in weinberger's own book
he blames mcfarland for the iran contra
affair even though
it's quite clear that the decision to to
trade arms for hostages
was reagan's and a decision taken
against
schultz and weinberger's uh advocacy one
of the few times they agreed uh
mcfarland on the other hand felt that
weinberger was uh
had all this military of power that they
had assembled and he was unwilling to
use it there was a this large there's
this odd thing where the diplomats
wanted to be warriors and and the
warriors didn't didn't really think that
they would have used military power
we have a little different look in it
now after operation desert storm but
this this was what happened during the
reagan years the military establishment
had been through vietnam and
had learned a lot of negative lessons
from that and weinberger was reluctant
to use a military power so in any case
these two guys became the villains
anything that that
that went wrong from the white house
from weinberger's point of view was
mcfarland's fault
and weinberger from from mcfarland's
perspective was an obstacle to
everything uh including arms control
and
and a successful u.s soviet relationship
which mcfarland very very much wanted
you see from this rundown it doesn't the
conservative liberal or conservative
moderate
dichotomy that everybody has doesn't fit
too neatly i mean mcfarland was
was in the
camp of the moderates and the pragmatist
on u.s soviet relationships he was a
conservative on
the contras
and on the question of lebanon i don't
know how you categorized him but he and
schultz both were the foremost advocates
of of the use of military power in in in
lebanon i'm going to jump all over the
place just come to mind landon parvin
landon's one of my favorite people in
the reagan white house and a a kind of
uh underrated uh sort of guy although i
i see he's now sort of getting his due
for these speeches that he writes at the
gridiron he he was he had been nancy
reagan's speech writer
and he wrote a very fine
speech uh he wrote he did a lot of the
humor speeches he did a lot of the
gridiron speeches and he did speeches
for for
contributed to speeches by both reagan's
uh
wrote the aids speech
got really
torn apart in that speech because i
think he would have gone further nancy
reagan would have gone further than
than reagan was willing to go but landon
parvin had made a singular contribution
during this
long and difficult period of trying to
bring reagan out of the
the iran contra morass he was this
principal speechwriter on this speech
where reagan finally sort of owned up
up to the his responsibility where he
says that my heart and mind tell me one
thing and the facts tell me another
which was as close as reagan ever got
publicly to admitting uh
that he he had in fact traded arms for
hostages now if you had ronald reagan in
this program today he'd revert it
and he'd tell you that he hadn't but
landon once said i think i quote him in
the book as saying that what ronald
reagan was really saying was i didn't do
it and i'll never do it again and i
think that landon had uh
uh had insights into reagan that were
that were
uh on the whole very accurate and he had
a close working relationship with uh
with nancy reagan which which didn't
hurt
uh before we go on to somebody
less known nancy reagan
well nancy reagan uh
was the constant protector of her
husband
she
had a lot to do with the way
who was chosen and who wasn't chosen for
the for the white house staff she was a
large pain in the knee to a lot of the
people
on the staff
but
nancy reagan
did not often
she often did not get her way on on
policy she advocated i mean
you wouldn't have had star wars you
probably wouldn't have the commitment to
the contras you certainly wouldn't have
had the trip to bitburg if nancy reagan
had had her way and nancy reagan thought
that
ronald reagan want to get rid of casper
weinberger casper weinberger i think
served longer as secretary of defense
than all but won secretary of defense in
the history of the country so
she was very influential on on
schedule
she was very influential in the
immediate confines of the white house
staff but ronald reagan had a stubborn
streak in him and on policy he he he
often
followed usually followed what he
thought was right not which often was
not what nancy reagan would have had him
do how how open was she to you for this
book she was very helpful to to me for
this book because
she understood that i was trying to
to
find out what made ronald reagan tick
and she was helpful to me i have written
a lot of negative things about nancy
reagan over the years i guess we
i don't know we sort of reached an armed
truce
and i was never her favorite cup of tea
nor her mind but i have to tell you that
i think she was
she she gave me insights into into
reagan about
that only only she possesses uh item
she she sees the importance of the
alcoholism of course
of his alcoholic
father but she also sees that ronald
reagan
spent his youth moving from town to town
his family moved almost every year there
for
for uh like the first nine or ten years
of ronald reagan's life and this
nomadicness made it very difficult for
ronald reagan to form boyhood
friendships
and if you think about it that would
have to be true because you were
you know you'd just be in town for a few
months and then you'd move on and so he
sort of developed a kind of a life of of
of his own i always felt that
but i think that inside of hers is
particularly particularly helpful and
there were several others by the way i
mentioned this in the first joe uh the
len nossiger
washington times review talks about the
alcoholism thing and and also
says something about you says the son of
an alcoholic father mr cannon
who clearly believes much of the
psychiatric drivel that has been written
about the children of alcoholics
sympathetically blames many reagan
weaknesses such as his passivity and his
dislike of confrontation on the fact
that the former president too had an
alcoholic father
tackle that one well
i mean i don't uh well lynn was
relatively generous i mean the truth is
that uh
neither neither lynn or i have one
moment's uh
practice experience as a as a doctor i'm
not gaga about anything a psychiatrist
writes but most of the people who have
written about the influence of
alcoholism on families are not in fact
psychiatrists most of them are
psychologists and there there are
psychiatrists who have written there's a
whole variety of doctors who
and i there is a lot of sort of
pop psychology you know that are sent a
self-help books for
people who have not come to terms with
their childhood experiences
but there also are some very serious
studies where
where you take people who are that
there's one in particular i quote in
there
about the successful children of
alcoholics and they they do have certain
patterns they have they have
a liking most of them for harmony which
reagan did they have an ability to
create worlds of their own which reagan
had had in space
yeah to some degree i mean i i don't uh
uh i certainly i don't know about the
latter and i certainly i i hate this
harmony it just it i don't like to have
people
fighting in a in a room around me
but
but it seems to me that
i didn't write a psycho history of
reagan i mean i i write about that i
wrote about other influences but it
seems to me that you're writing we live
in the modern age people are affected by
what happens to them they are affected
by
child abuse
they are affected by by alcoholism they
are affected by
inadequate nutrition and if you are a
biographer of anyone and you find out
that a person
didn't eat properly didn't get to school
or had a particular condition you know
had uh
that
that
that affects you and i and and you have
a duty to write about it i don't think
that that there's a single touchstone
and the book doesn't at any point say
there is that you can just say aha
you know ronald reagan and i think that
that
is a child of an alcoholic and therefore
that explains his whole life or
they moved you know 27
times when he was a kid i'm deliberately
exaggerating that explains his whole
life but
all of these things contribute and and
and we we ought those of us who write
about people be aware of them
if ronald reagan and nancy reagan
sitting together talking about lou
cannon and all the stories you've
written and what they
thought of you
got any inkling is what they would say
god i haven't a clue i i would hope
ronald reagan once told me when
we'd had a little
a little uh battle about some story i'd
written and uh
that he knew that i uh i
tried to be fair
and that i it's and he said this to
somebody else in another context
i haven't a clue i imagine the
it would depend on the story of the
subject i think they'd probably uh
praise me for some things and run me
down on others and i i the only thing
that i would say to you brian is that i
never when i'm writing
that's thought never popped into my head
i don't you know i i want to be fair
because that should be a value of a
reporter it should be a value of a
historian but as far as your subject
you'd always like to have them like it
you know i don't feel good if i if
somebody says oh that that guy wrote a
rotten story about me but that isn't why
you're writing but you don't think they
thought you were trying to do a man
because you worked
no oh
no i don't think that at all i think
that that on the contrary uh
they thought that uh
that i i probably would try to be
fair-minded uh ronald reagan
probably thinks i'm
too liberal for his taste uh although
most people uh
don't feel that way about me but uh but
i don't think
i i don't really know i guess the honest
answer is i don't really know what they
think except that i do
i do think they don't think that i was
out to get them
and i never was
let me go back to some names um david
stockman
i think it was niskanen's uh
illness cannons bill and this cannons
phrase about stockman but didn't it i
think it was niskanen who said that he
was more brilliant than wise
about stockman i think that's right
uh stockman uh
had a tremendous iq you know probably
more than anybody in the in the reagan
uh
the reagan cabinet uh brilliant man but
he
he uh he saw himself as the center of
of the reagan universe and of what he
called the reagan rebel revolution if
you read david stockman's book
you you
you get i left with the distinct
impression that all this would have
worked if they'd only done what what
what i david stockman had had thought
they should done as as a matter of fact
i think
stockman has a lot of
stockman's book is is a valuable book
because stockman does tell you an awful
lot
about the
the uh
unrealistic and sometimes even goofy
economic assumptions
of the reagan administration but a lot
of those assumptions were stockman's as
well as reagan's and there's one thing
where i particularly take him to task
there because
stockman's argument you know is that
ronald reagan wasn't willing to uh
to really come to grips with the budget
that if you gave him these options he
always took the he always took the
middle ground option well most people
would stockman himself according to
reagan and according to other people who
worked for reagan would often say that
that some of these these more draconian
things
uh
cuts in the budget that
that you couldn't do those because they
weren't politically
acceptable well in his book stockman
doesn't say that in his book stockman
says in effect that if they had carried
out his program they'd have had the
reagan revolution i think that's that's
not quite fair
well we're on david stockman because
it's something that you write a lot
about uh he played a role in the
louisville debate back in 1984. well he
was a stockman was was
terrific as the uh he first came to
reagan's attention in 80 uh
uh
i think probably got the the job of
budget director because he had so
skillfully impersonated
first john anderson and then jimmy
carter in the rehearsals for the debate
and and in 84 he was doing what he'd
done in 80. he played mondale and
according
according to the people who
who uh
wanted to blame somebody other than
reagan for his
terrible performance in the louisville
debate uh stockman was supposed to have
brutalized i think was
paul axl's phrase reagan by just
destroying him in this commercial in
this rehearsal for the debate that
stockton played mondale and just tore
reagan
uh to pieces and shook reagan's
confidence but the real reason as stu
spencer is quoted and saying in this
book a real reason that reagan
reagan didn't do well in that debate was
that he was overconfident and lazy he
didn't prepare for it i don't think it's
fair
i take stockman to task for a lot of
things i don't think he can blame
stockman or dick darmon or any of these
other people for reagan's performance in
that debate you have to blame ronald
reagan
whose performance it was when you're
talking about
people
early in the book
you suggest that richard nixon had a
tremendous impact on the first cabinet
choices of ronald reagan well i i
reprint a memo from nixon that has not
not
appeared anywhere before which i felt
fortunate to have
and i think it
it shows that ronald reagan did in fact
follow
nixon's advice and a number of things
but it wasn't just that memo nixon would
call
reagan from time to time i mean he
called him in times of crisis he called
him after the iran contra
reagan consulted with him before he went
to moscow
most of
the republicans who were sort of the
part of the republican establishment in
washington and who were part of
reagan's team
had had had been members of the nixon
administration jim
jim baker had been george schultz casper
weinberger these were all people who had
worked and lots of others that had
worked for richard nixon i think i
i quote mike dever in there saying at
some point that reagan
thought of of nixon as the president
and uh
and he certainly uh although reagan
marched to a different drummer he
certainly did
pay a lot of attention and have a lot of
respect for richard nixon's advice
we didn't really know that that much
during the reagan years
because
at the outset of the reagan
administration what you had a situation
where you were quite close to watergate
i mean you're only six years away from
the resignation and the white house
press office and others in the
administration
that did their best to conceal nixon's
influence with reagan that they didn't
want it known they didn't want they
never advertised it but it was it was
always there did ron on another issue on
personnel did ronald reagan personally
choose
judge bork and scalia and ginsburg and
kennedy and all those names did he have
anything to say about that he he doesn't
even mention you know
he doesn't even mention uh
a ginsburg
or kennedy
in his memoirs in bork he has the
reference and bork is a reference that
uh
things were going bad you know it was
when
nancy had her operation and other things
he mentions pork in passing in a
sentence
no he didn't have he didn't have
anything to do
with the selection
of any of those people they were uh
most of them were chosen at justice or
or are
but what he did have something to do
with uh curiously enough was
the selection of sandra day o'connor
the first woman in the supreme court
ronald reagan had made a promise during
the
during the 80 campaign that one of his
first nominees to the court would be a
woman he chose to interpret that promise
not as if he'd said one of the first but
as if he'd said the first and he never
interviewed i mean of course
of
smith and nice and the people came up
with the list of names as they would for
any president you don't expect the
president to be carting those names
around in his head but he never
interviewed anybody else for the
o'connor seat on the court other than
o'connor i mean he he liked her
and uh he wanted to name a woman and
once he'd interviewed it uh her that
that that that was it
we haven't got much time and in the last
uh
uh chapter visions and and legacies are
a couple of sentences i underline i just
want to ask you about them
[Music]
you write similarly the greatness of
reagan
was that he carried a shining vision of
america inside him
i think that's right you know i i i hope
this isn't one of the other
sentences you underline because it'll
ruin your clothes but uh but but uh i
quote uh
paraphrase walter lippman there who said
that
the greatness of de gaulle wasn't that
uh he was in in france but that france
was in him and i think america was in
reagan he he had he had a view
of of this country's goodness and of
this country's mission and an an idea
that america stood for something very
special particularly in its commitment
to freedom
he he believed that he always believed
that he believes it still and he and he
expressed it very well that's not the
other line
the other line was his career as an
actor had prepared him for the
presidency
uh elaborate on that and i also want to
ask you whether or not you think we'll
ever have another actor as president it
it prepared him for the presidency but i
think i do conclude that it hadn't
prepared him uh fully and sufficiently
it prepared him to be a performer it had
prepared him to be able to take center
stage dominate it can communicate to the
american people to
to to know to know what his role was but
what it had not done is it had not
equipped him analytically for to be
president no we're never going to have
another actor because the world that
ronald reagan comes from doesn't exist
hollywood has changed
there are no recreation of
baseball games anymore there's no
dixon as it was television has
homogenized america
there's no there's
the world that ronald reagan came
through and came from
doesn't really exist anymore
all of ronald reagan's
adversaries as well as ronald reagan's
friends surely must know that he was one
of a kind
last question what's next for lou cannon
besides returning to the west coast to
be the washington post correspondent
well i don't know i i want to uh
i guess the thing that interests me most
is uh
is i want to write about the way
the
west works the way
america works in a country where we're
all
i think california is a wave of the
future i think that
white middle-aged males are going to be
a minority i think we're going to have
more hispanics we're going to have more
asians we're going to have more
immigrants of any of every kind
and that's
some people are afraid of that i
i think that's a very exciting prospect
and i and i'd like to write about it
here's what the book looks like the
title president reagan the role of a
lifetime by lou cannon thank you very
much for being here
former president ronald reagan died
saturday he was 93 the